he puts the sleeping bag in the back and
then him and his buddy start butt
[ __ ] each other super hard like doing
truck stuff right
he said butt Trucking yeah no they're
they're really going to town on each
other's [ __ ] like how long was the
duration 330 miles
[Music]
hey Bart have you heard your truck game
I love trucks big ribs is anybody is
anybody else here a truck guy I'm a
truck guy I like trucks I had a truck
but like I can't stand a truck I don't
have a truck anymore trucks test me on
trucks I'll [ __ ] tell you their
engine sizes and [ __ ] okay holy [ __ ]
I'll tell you the [ __ ] histories of
them
what do you know we know what the Ford
F-150 EV well I think they caught the
lightning the lightning correct new
lightning it has a front as well because
it doesn't need a motor trunk yep I just
realized Tesla's have them yep the new
lightning also has a frunk too pretty
cool that's lit give us more
um so it's their first electric truck I
think they misnamed it by calling the
lightning because the original SVT SVT
Lightning was the fastest production
truck of the time zero to 60 in I think
under 5.5 seconds is that fast because I
go pretty fast the truck we're talking
to yeah it was fast this is dope and uh
and then they came out with the SRT10 by
Dodge and they beat that so that was the
fastest production truck at the time and
then now they're coming out with this
electric truck and I think they wanted
to re like brand it but then to me I'm
like the lightning is meant to be a
[ __ ] muscle gas guzzling machine but
also I also get it like a likely onwards
lightning you know something all right
fine go ahead take it but to me it's
misnamed
T-Mobile or something yeah [ __ ] wagon
[ __ ] wagon wow really you're not about
no I think it's cool I think it's cool
that they're transcending but I like the
Cyber truck is [ __ ] cool right so
cool the F-150 Evie is [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] redesign it don't [ __ ] do it
what does it look like does it look so
AK don't make it an F-150 just make an
EV Truck Yeah do some other [ __ ] with it
it just looks like a truck yeah exactly
it's not special wow is this not even
fun to show that's sad but but let me
ask you this so you just said this is
like pretty tight and stuff and then
you're saying I think that could be
pretty tight is this tight
um a YouTuber charged up his lightning
to 200 miles
almost all of it that's almost all of
its 230 mile range this is range for a
trip
to his mechanic 32 miles away to pick up
a 1930 Ford Model A until at home one of
the earliest cars nice and two at home
however as soon as he started pulling
the empty trailer the Lightnings range
started dropping like a [ __ ] Stone
and in the end the 64 mile Journey
sucked up 150 miles of range so he only
went 64 miles 64 miles 150 miles of
range from their battery because the
towing capacity the problemo with the
electric where you know how like if
you're on your phone right it's like
yeah it's going to last all day but if
you're in video mode or if you're face
timing you know it's only going to last
a few hours so it's the same theme where
if you're just driving by yourself the
range is 250 miles but if we're actually
going to try to do some truck [ __ ] with
it it's not gonna last it's kind of like
charging a phone with your phone
expecting your phone to last as long so
now you're just an [ __ ] who's driving
a truck you don't even [ __ ] use
because you can't you can't even do
truck stuff can't do truck stuff so
those are going to buy each other you
can't do truck stuff with a lot of the
truck consumer Market doesn't
well a lot of the consumer Market that
would buy electric trucks don't do truck
stuff
I don't think I'll have a problem turn
the dagger dude that's what I was so
excited about the Cyber truck because
that [ __ ] had three motors
because they he knew about this [ __ ] so
the the range was like 500 miles holy
[ __ ] so Disney YouTubers started putting
this to the real test right so he's like
okay well if this is like this what's
gonna happen if I do other truck stuff
right so he gets truck stuff he gets a
roll away sleeping bag he puts it in the
bed of the truck right this is what he
has and then lost mileage right away
this is when he has 200 he has back to
230 miles of charge right so he puts the
roll he puts the sleeping bag in the
back and then him and his buddy start
butt [ __ ] each other super hard like
doing truck stuff right I mean it's true
he said butt Trucking yeah no they're
they're really going to town on each
other's [ __ ] like how long was the
duration this was for 34 or 30 miles
that's too long yeah and he says that he
he lost 200 miles of charge
from that so so now it's looking a
little bit different for these trucks
yeah sounds bad for the truck Market
truck voice truck voice what else is
truck stuff dude just like what you put
a bunch of straps you put you put
something in the back you put a bunch of
straps on it you [ __ ] shake it you're
like yeah that's not going anywhere
[Laughter]
that was in a commercial recently
actually anyways
um I think that trucks are really really
great for actually short distances
anyway I feel like when you do truck
stuff especially maybe it's because it's
a city thing I feel like the most times
I ever use trucks is one to move
or two to ride in the truck bed and have
fun yeah so if those two things take
away style right those two things take
like 50 of the chunk the trunk that's
like a really bad truck that is useless
it's a [ __ ] truck why would you even buy
a truck if you're well I don't get it so
wait you said you said residentially
like people don't even use the trucks
really I think a lot of people don't
are you talking about the small dick
guys
I'm talking about something I'm talking
about the lifted two-wheel drive guys
with truck nuts yeah yeah but you know
not everybody some people buy trucks in
in thinking they're gonna do that and
they just never do because at the same
time like 90 of people that buy like a
raptor because such a sick truck they're
like I'm gonna [ __ ] tear up the road
or the dirt but then once they get it
like oh [ __ ] it's too nice and most
people I know that owner Raptor don't
actually go off-roading um that's my
favorite truck though so [ __ ] sick
when we're at the big island in Hawaii
like everybody that lives on the island
because it's like to get anywhere on the
island you need to and legally in Hawaii
you can ride in the back Isn't that cool
so cool so [ __ ] cool so over there
probably no one's gonna have [ __ ] EV
trucks
unless they put us solar panel get that
Hawaiian Sun up in there that's what
they need to do or if you can charge it
in ABC but it needs to be a part of the
body yeah not just like a solar panel
yeah
oh yeah it's like a SUV truck thing
right
have there been any like toe videos to
see if you could do actual truck [ __ ] or
no or just battery just dies I don't
know I don't know but there's a secret
compartment that you could put your golf
bag in that's really cool
you're supposed to drive like a [ __ ]
small car dude like a [ __ ] yard or
something or a [ __ ] golf cart or a
smart car yeah dude literally all of you
guys losers
why are we all losing
[Applause]
I've been seeing them on the road you
losers I don't know too much about them
because I think what brand is that loser
brand who are you kids in
those look [ __ ] weird oh you know
what's crazy the new Hummers have you
guys seen that hey the front looks like
those uh bladeless fans the dysons
right thousand horsepower or a thousand
pounds of torque yeah but if you put two
passenger in you only get 10 Port tours
we can start [ __ ] each other 10 pork
ten pork some pork and the resell on
those guys are crazy so so it's a pretty
good uh Truck Yeah because uh when you
pre-ordered it it was like 100 100 G's
now uh because they're so rare you could
flip them for 250. and people are buying
them can you believe that what do you
think of Hummer EV Bert
I don't like anything with it easy it's
not even a Teslas well that's because
it's its own thing the Cyber truck is
its own thing like so to me I'm like
don't try to [ __ ] like like build the
saxophone and then put a speaker in
there and go oh I'm playing a musical
instrument just make some other [ __ ]
that was actually a that's actually a
really dope thing when they did that
with instruments that's cheating that's
not dope just just making it like like a
keyboard right they don't try to make a
keyboard look like a grand piano it's
its own thing
not the good ones yeah a [ __ ] cork
Triton doesn't look like a [ __ ] grand
piano part how pissed were you when Liz
was playing that flute huh I thought it
was kind of cool
I was livid I called my mom we both
[ __ ] yelled about it for three hours
yeah we're pissed so is the Cyber truck
just the biggest like rug pull and yeah
when's that coming out oh man
I've seen some pretty big rug pulls
though
so is it never coming out what's the
deal with it I put in 100 bucks if we
order one so you should get your soon
right apparently not it'd be 2022 or is
it 20 20. Elon just tweeted about it he
said they're coming still I think that's
supposed to be 20 20 or something yeah
it was supposed to be way earlier he was
bragging about it too and I'm like dude
stop bragging about the [ __ ] thing we
already like it yeah just let us send it
just send it yeah it was only 100 bucks
to hold your space and I put in 100
bucks do you know what the retail is
going to be for the Cybertron 38 really
I think that's like the lowest base
model there's like it's smaller oh the
Cyber Shop is actually smaller than the
one they even like demo that's so cool
you guys know what's [ __ ] cool about
the Cyber Shop 39.9 39 939 the coolest
part about the Cyber truck is Elon is so
smart right that he uh was studying cars
and he goes why the [ __ ] are cars so
expensive and he realized most of the
cost of a car isn't even the motor the
chassis or the material is the machines
that you have to make to stamp and roll
the metal so you know all those cool
curves assembly line stuff yeah the
machines is why the car cars are
expensive so for him he was like well if
I make a truck with straight edges I
don't need those stupid ass but my cost
will go down and if I can have a car
with straight edges I can use way
thicker material because I don't have to
roll and stab and do all that stuff so
you can go stainless steel I don't need
Paint it's Dent proof never need to
clear coat that [ __ ] and I can build a
car that's way better than yours for
half the price wow I'm like dude that's
[ __ ] cool man which is why he rug
pulled you guys you like really know
about cars or talk about automobiles
[ __ ] time yeah and there's no
dealership middleman up charge yeah see
I like I like I think I like cars the
way you like football I think you do
yeah bust nuts over [ __ ] V8 motors
Steve's over here busting us over the
Colts that's why I feel bad for for
people that like truck guys that buy
this EV and expect it to be a truck that
sucks
but according to him Evie the LA truck
guys and they're like this is perfect no
yeah there will be you mean like Ikea
drivers were like I need it for my Ikea
room
[Laughter]
okay